[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du Grand JIT des
territoires voici tout de suite les
titres de l'actualité avant la migration
des oiseaux sauvages 64 millions de
canards d'élevage sont en train d'être
vaccinés contre la grippe aviaire cette
campagne est un soulagement pour les
producteurs chez qui la rédaction de via
occcitan s'est rendue dans un instant
depuis le 1er octobre la baguette de
pain n'a plus tout à fait le même goût
vous vous en doutez elle contient
désormais moins de selle selon une
recommandation de l'Organisation
Mondiale de la Santé via ATV Martinique
nous expliquera pourquoi dans ce journal
à ces Stas en Gironde des scientifiques
testent depuis près de 20 ans des
solutions innovantes pour une gestion à
la fois écologique et économique durable
de la forêt TV7 la chaîne du groupe
sud-ouest à Bordeaux nous en révélera la
teneur enfin nous irons à la rencontre
de Bernard qui a 67 ans vient d'obtenir
son diplôme de docteur en médecine et
oui et qui va exercer TBO a rencontré ce
personnage hors du commun pour nous et
commençons ce journal avec octobre rose
la campagne annuelle de communication
destinée à sensibiliser les femmes au
dépistage du cancer du sein et à
collecté des fonds pour la recherche
àastia depuis 5 ans une marche réunie
des centaines de participants à travers
les rues de la cité une marche dans la
bonne humeur comme l'explique le docteur
Orsini soli au micro de Gilles pierrich
pour télépaisé sur place c'est le
démarrage du mois d'Octobre Rose donc
pour nous c'est la fête et puis en même
temps euh c'est la possibilité euh
d'avoir beaucoup de dons aussi à
l'occasion d'aujourd'hui mais aussi de
toutes les marches qu'on va avoir durant
le mois d'octobre parce que nous en
avons une dizaine plus de nombreuxes
autres
événements tout à fait autre chose
rendue obligatoire par la France la
vaccination des canards contre
l'influenza aviaire a débuté pour le
plus grand soulagement des producteurs
de foie gras 64 millions de palmipèes
vont être vaccinés ces prochaines
semaines pour limiter la propagation du
virus et permettre enfin aux éleveurs de
mettre fin à cette épisouti qui sévit
depuis près de 3 ans Geoffrey pri s'est
rendu dans le gerse pour via occitan
regardez plus de 10 1 canards sur les
30000 de cet élevage à la barart-ête à
l'ouest du gerse sont vaccinés contre la
grippe aviaire une vaccination
nécessaire et attendue par les éleveurs
fortement impactés ces dernières années
on n pas voulu rentrer les canards tant
que le vaccin n'était pas là euh c'était
impossible de continuer ainsi autant
arrêter donc c'est un soulagement pour
nous enfin que le vaccin soit là la
vaccination est obligatoire et réalisée
par des vétérinaires qui se rendent dans
les élevages elle est effectuée sur des
canards âgés de 10 jours par par voie
souscutanée avec une deuxème dose de
rappel 18 jours plus tard c'est une
vaccination qui qui limite très très
bien l'apparition de signe clinique par
contre on on peut pas être sûr et
certain qu'il y ait pas de
d'introduction de virus sauvage quand
même dans le dans l'élevage et c'est
pour ça qu'on réalise en fait en
parallèle un gros monitoring dans
l'élevage à partir du moment où ils sont
où ils sont vaccinés pour vérifier qu'il
y ait pas de de virus sauvag qui circule
coût total de cette vaccination cette
année pour les 64 millions de canards
million d'euros couvert à 85 % par
l'État cette année et en 2024 le vaccin
qu'est-ce qu'il va faire il va réduire
la capacité de diffusion il va réduire
les effets voilà c'est ça qu'on voulait
c'est qu'on a une diffusion qui se qui
se limite et à terme on puisse voir si
ce n'est disparaître en tout cas voir de
façon résiduelle réapparaître des foyers
une protection collective pour favoriser
une filière qui espère se relancer pour
les fêtes de fin d'année sans l'ombre de
la grippe
aviaire vous l'avez sans doute remarqué
notre baguette de pain n'a plus du tout
le même goût depuis le début du mois les
professionnels de la filière ont diminué
la quantité de sel dans le pain afin de
contribuer à la réduction de 30 % de la
consommation de selle à l'horizon 2025
préconisé par l'Organisation Mondiale de
la Santé ha siultidas s'est rendu dans
une boulangerie de fort- de- France pour
ATV Martinique regardez en petit-
déjeuner ou en en cas la baguette de
pain est un indispensable pour Alic un
sandwich le matin peut-être qu' va faire
autrement et ensuite je vais travailler
son pain du jour a sa saveur habituelle
pourtant dès ce 1er octobre le tôaux de
sel présent dans la baguette diminue
elle passe de 1,5 g à 1,4 g pour 100 g
de farine un changement recommandé par
le gouvernement notamment pour lutter
contre l'hypertension artérielle le
changement passe inaperçu pour les
clients de cette boulangerie surtout
pour les pour les petits nous on essaie
de réduire le sel du coup moinen de sel
dans une baguette mais auss si le goût
est toujours là de toute façon c'est
c'est le principal si le gouvernement a
décidé comme ça je pense que pour nous
c'est c'est une bonne chose surtout nous
les martiniicains nous mangeons beaucoup
salé beaucoup sucré non c'est ça peut
être qu'une bonne chose à l'atelier la
mesure est en vigueur on avait déjà
l'habitude de baisser en selle on était
tombé sur les 16 g au kilo donc la la
législation actuelle nous nous oblige à
descendre à 14 g mais ce qui fait pas
une différence vraiment notable donc le
client ne va pas l'apercevoir c'est
c'est bien de descendre le sel par
rapport à la santé des gens sans altérer
le goût parce qu'il faut quand même
qu'on garde notre baguette craquante
croustillante et avec le goût qu'on a
toujours connu la bataille contre le sel
n'est pas un combat français
l'Organisation Mondiale de la Santé
recommande de réduire de 30 % sa
consommation de selle quotidienne d'ici
2025 en moyenne un adulte doit consommer
5 g de sel par jour en France l'adulte
type en consomme 2 à 3 g de trop sans
transition pour aider à la protection
des populations civiles association
gilet Ukraine sillonne la France à la
recherche de gilet parbal à la date de
viabilité dépassé ces gilets sont
reconditionnés dans un atelier protégé
de Bretagne pour être remis aux
autorités ukrainiennes l'association a
reçu 30 gilets de la part de la ville de
Limoge au total ce sont plus de 3000
gilets qui à ce jour ont été
reconditionnés et expédiés voici le
reportage de notre partenaire C al sur
place un gilet par bal a une durée de
vie optimale de 5 ans habituellement il
sont détruits ou partiellement recyclés
dans le meilleur des cas une association
a lancé une opération de collecte auprès
des polices municipales afin de les
expédier pour la protection des civils
en Ukraine en fait plutôt que de les
détruire en les brûlant on préfère donc
du coup les envoyer en Ukraine à
destination des civiles pour les
protéger directement on est à plus de
3000 gilets parbales envoyés en Ukraine
et également en Arménie parce qu'on se
mobilise aussi sur sur les événements en
Arménie le gilet parbal fait désormais
partie du paysage les forces de l'ordre
s'équipent pour travailler au au
quotidien alors ce qui se passe c'est
que d'une fois qu'il a été utilisé c'est
une matière qui est souple que Velard à
la fois résistant et souple il peut
quand même tomber il est résistant il
est résistant également aussi à l'eau la
composition c'est plusieurs pqus de
clévelard qui vont être qui vont amortir
les balles les gilet reste efficace
au-delà de la durée d'usage préconisée
nous avons une autre utilisation au
service des populations cette hyper
consommation systématique avec les
durées de préemption sont quand même
très particulières à nos société
occidentale c'est une trentaine de
gilets que la police municipale de
Limoge a remis à l'association ces
gilets vont être traités en Bretagne et
transiteront par la Pologne avant la
remise aux autorités
ukrainiennes voilà et l'association ne
compte pas s'arrêter à l'Ukraine une
première cargaison de gilet parbal vient
d'arriver également en Arménie toujours
dans l'optique de protéger les civils de
ce pays en guerre comme chaque semaine
je vous propose de partir à la
découverte des innovations
des territoires en matière de
responsabilité environnementale
commençons avec ce concept présenté par
Renault au Salon x mobility du qui
regorge vous allez voir d'intelligence
artificielle des innovations rendu possi
grâce à un partenariat entre la marque
losang et de grand groupes français
Anthony piton aurait bien aimé l'essayer
pour notre partenaire LM
TV
c'est un prototype qui sert de
laboratoire à bord de la human first
vision plus d'une vingtaine
d'innovations promettent une expérience
inédite la première expérience c'est la
surveillance en fait de tes donniers
physiologiques avec ton
électrocardiogramme c'était assez
impressionnant je dois dire je suis
arrivée la voiture qui s'ouvrait toute
seule on a pu aussi mesurer mon cœur on
a même pu me dire si j'étais stressé
reconnaissance faciale surveillance de
l'état de santé du conducteur ou encore
son im par des bulles sonores privatives
on est plus proche d'une intelligence
artificielle roulante que d'une simple
voiture moderne dans le cas en fait le
conducteur est en train de faire un
malaise ça ça peutêre détecté par le
véhicule le véhicule va prendre un
certainombre d'action par exemple garer
le véhicule et de contacter en fait les
urgences une ambulance voire même de
faire une vionférence avecvec un docteur
la humanion restera un concept car mais
ses fonctions seront reprises dans les
futurs modèles Renault on on a voulu
démontrer l'écosystème qu'il
fonctionnait et puis montrer que cet
écosystème il était capable d'amener des
produits des services dans la mobilité
de demain et on aura euh dès 2025 un
certain nombre des innovations qui
apparaîtront dans des véhicules de série
bon nombre des technologie du prototype
pourrait donc un jour faire partie du
quotidien voilà cette technologie mise
en œuvre ont pour ambition vous en
doutez de diminuer l'impact carbone des
véhicules du futur trouver des solutions
innovantes c'est aussi l'ambition des
scientifiques qui testent depuis près de
20 ans des solutions innovantes pour une
gestion à la fois écologique et
économique durable de la forêt en
nouvelle- Aquitaine Dominique Parmentier
du groupe sud-ouest s'est rendu à Cestas
en Gironde pour TV7 regardez dans cette
parcelle expérimentale appelée arboretom
les chercheurs de l'inrae ont planté il
y a une douzaine d'années une trentaine
d'espèces d'arbres de provenance
différentes pour tester à la FO FO leur
productivité et leur adaptation au
changement climatique ici dans notre
région c'est des Cypris donc on voit que
ces ces espèces là ben ne sont pas
adapté justement à cet environnement on
voit déjà plusieurs sujets morts on voit
des ici tout en haut une descente de CIM
très très nette quant aux Eucalyptus s
ils ont poussé ici plus vite que
d'autres espèces une autre
expérimentation consiste justement à
mélanger les essences en introduisant
des essences plus méridionales mieux
adapté aux fortes chaleur et à la
sécheresse ici sur cette parcelle
conservatoire on travaille sur
l'amélioration génétique du pasain
maritime il faut savoir que c'est une
espèce qui détient une très grande
diversité génétique chaque population de
pain maritime s'est adapté pour des
environnements très différents donc dans
le cadre d'un programme d'amélioration
génétique du pain maritime on va
chercher à croiser des individus issus
de ces différentes populations pour
essayer de rassembler chez un même
individu des caractères favorable un peu
plus loin on expérimente ce qu'on
appelle des itinéraires syvicoles
innovants on teste différentes manières
de cultiver la forêt en vue de d'adapter
la silviculture du massif landais au
changement climatique on a des
itinérair intensif à vocation de
production de bois ou de biomasse et on
a également des itinéraires plus
agroécologique des expériences menées
avec et pour les acteurs de la gestion
forestière qu'il soit public ou
privé à l'heure où la filière textile
vugienne se cherche un avenir le centre
d'essai textile Laurin installé à Épinal
depuis une vingtaine d'années s'avère
être un atout pour imaginer et lancer de
nouveaux produits le laboratoire a
présenté il y a quelques jours un
prototype de machine d'explosion à la
vapeur qui doit faciliter le recyclage
du bois et des fibres textiles un
reportage de notre partenaire vuche
télévision sur place
sorte de cocote minute géante cette
machine est l'objet de toutes les
attentions ce prototype d'explosion à
vapeur doit participer à améliorer les
procédés de recyclage du bois donc
c'estàd enlever les additifs qui sont
présents dans le bois déchet dans les
anciens panneaux de particules les
anciens déchets d'éléments d'ameublement
pour pouvoir recycler ces particules
pour en refaire des matériaux mais ce
qui en fait une machine unique en France
et peut-être dans le monde c'est que
cette technologie accepte aussi des
fibres comme le lin ou le chanvre auquel
on donnerait une vie donc pour produire
de nouveaux isolants un isolant pour
l'habitat par exemple à partir de
plantes locales peut améliorer les
techniques actuelles pour aller vers
l'application textile
habîment ces recherches universitaires
intéressent hautement la région grandest
qui participe avec l'Europe et des
investisseurs privés à cette phase test
le réacteur d'explosion à vapeur peut
contenir 22 lit de matière et sera 30
fois plus grand pour être utilisé à
l'échelle industrielle parle exposion
vapeur parce que l'eau pénètre dans les
fibres de bois durant la la cuisson et
au moment de au moment où on décomprime
le réacteur l'eau qui était dans le bois
se vaporise et éclate explose le les
fibres et ce n'est pas tout l'eau
injectée pour créer de la vapeur est
aussi récupérée répondant aux attentes
de la chimie dite durable avec des
vertus différentes en fonction de la
fibre qui était dans la cuve on récupère
également du liquide qui contient de
nombreuses molécules qui peuvent être
valorisé dans pour des tas
d'applications dans l'industrie
cosmétique pharmaceutique et on a
actuellement l'map des projets de
recherche sur la valorisation de ces
liquides qu'on récupère du bioéthanol
par exemple les recherches vont
consister à étudier la qualité des
matières extraites par ce procédé peu
énergivore un procédé qui existe depuis
le début du 20e siècle mais dont l'étude
avait été abandonné après la Seconde
Guerre mondiale avec l'avèement et
l'abondance du
pétrole phénomè expqué ou inexpliqué en
Champagne les Rémois ont eu la surprise
de voir apparaître de longs filaments un
peu partout dans le ciel avant de finir
au sol intrigué Antonin l'huiler est
allé poser la question à un spécialiste
de la nature pour le journal de l'Union
et sa réponse est étonnante
écoutez ce drôle de phénomène s'appelle
le ballooning il s'agit d'un moyen de
locomotion aérien pour les petites
araignées afin de se lancer elle lèvent
leur abdomen et expulse un fil et
utilise les courants d'air chaud parfois
sur plusieurs kilomètres mais alors
pourquoi en ce moment nous avons posé la
question auurai moi Alexis bourgeois
trésorier de l'association mission
Spider il nous précise que l'automne est
une période très active pour les
araignées avec de nombreux déplacements
notamment pour se reproduire et si vous
êtes arachnophobe pas d'inquiétude ces
araignées ne mesurent que 2 à 3 mm une
page économie dans ce jour le coût de la
vie peut-être un frein à l'implantation
de fonctionnaires dans certains
territoires depuis des années des élus
au savoyard réclamer une indemnité pour
faire face au coût de la vie dans
certains départements limitrophes de la
Suisse le gouvernement a finalement
décidé de l'octroyer aux fonctionnaires
qui travaillent dans 62 communes de la
Haute Savoie et de lin les précisions du
ministre de la Fonction publique au
micro d'Emmanuel Jo notre partenaire h
montbanc je crois qu'on vient répondre à
une problématique particulière et au
fond c'est une mesure de justice que je
suis venu annoncer aujourd'hui elle a un
coût financier 25 millions d'euros qui
sera assumé C 25 millions d'euros qui
seront donnés en pouvoir d'achat aux
29000 agents de la fonction publique
dans 62 communes mais c'est un outil
supplémentaire donné aux employeurs pour
regagner en attractivité et Infiné
rendre le service public je vous propose
maintenant de parler éducation et de
confirmer ce vieux proverbe la valeur
n'attend pas le nombre des années 30 ans
après avoir abandonné ses études de
médecine pour des raisons financières
Bernard Pinot a repris son parcours
universitaire et vient d'obtenir son
diplôme Mael delmur l'a rencontré à
Brest pour TBO et c'est étonnant
regardez même pas mort tu es venu à la
test voici les premiers mots de Bernard
Pinot à sa mère qui a dû attendre 67 ans
pour voir son fils devenir médecin
généraliste ce jeudi le jeune nouveau
médecin passéit sa soutenance à
l'université de médecine de Brest avant
d'être diplômé j'ai une partie âge
normal étude jusqu'en 6e année un petit
arrêt de 30 ans et puis ensuite reprise
euh parce qu'entretemps ils avaient
inventé le scanner ils ont inventé l'IRM
ils ont inventé l'échographie ils ont
inventé des nouvelles thérapeutiques
après une rapide délibération le jry a
décerné la mention la plus élevée
possible à Bernard Pinot le médecin
souhaite maintenant exercer à temps
partiel sur l'île de sain en remplaçant
un mois sur deux la docteuresse sur
place une bonne nouvelle pour l'île de
sain dont le maire attend déjà avec
impatience son nouveau médecin
généraliste une île sans médecin ou
infirmière c'est une catastrophe donc on
est très content si une solution est
trouvée en remplacement du docteur
mastias dont on regrettera le départ
mais pour le moment l'île de Saint va
devoir tout de même attendre début
novembre pour pouvoir débarquer sur ces
terre le nouveau médecin éducation
encore chaque année en France ce sont
100000 jeunes qui sortent du système
scolaire sans diplôme alors pour remédié
l'école des 15 c'est son nom mise sur un
concept ambitieux l'intégration par le
sport alors c'est autour des valeurs du
rugby que les élèves apprennent le
dépassement de soi le respect le goût de
l'effort aussi un reportage de Nathan
Vachet pour TL7 dans la
Loire l'école est terminée pour
aujourd'hui mais ses élèves retournent
en cours l'école des 15 est née en 2013
à exenprence elle est arrivée en mars
2022 à Saint-Étienne et accueille
aujourd'hui 40 jeunes du CM2 à la 3e
dans le but de lutter contre le
décrochage scolaire c'est mieux on peut
rire et on est moins nombreux genre on
peut poser des questions et tout on peut
parler et tout c'est mieux je suis fier
parce qu'on est dans dans dans comme une
salle à 5 ou à 4 donc ben c'est plus
simple pour nous de de faire les devoirs
de faire le soutien très bien ces élèves
viennent au minimum 12 heur par semaine
sur leur tempsée scolaire l'après-midi
est divisé en TR temps autour desquels
des échanges ludiques du soutien
scolaire et de de rugby sont observé
pour pouvoir au mieux accompagner
l'enfant dans un cadre de proximité pour
le coup c'est très enrichissant parce
qu'on a autant de jeunes que de profils
différents on a une relation assez assez
particulière avec eux puisque on est on
n'est pas l'éducation nationale on n'est
pas la protection d'enfance non plus on
est des des personnes qui leur tendent
la main et on leur dit à chaque fois on
te tend la main si tu la veux pas ce
sera un autre qui va la prendre mais
pour le coup on croit en eux avant le
goûter tous au vestière direction le
stade de Janon pour frapper le ballon
aual avant d'entrer à l'école des 15
certains n'avaient jamais joué au rugby
je connaissais mais je je savais pas
jouer on court on parle c'est bien
l'activité sportive a été déterminé pour
ses valeurs l'école des 15 met en avant
l'idée d'apprendre de ces erreurs de
progresser dans la difficulté mais
surtout d'aller de l'avant en équipe que
ce soit dans la salle de cours ou sur le
rectangle
vert sport et éducation et bien Régis
Henri les a toujours conjugué avec
bonheur il fêtera ses 100 ans en février
prochain
si les années ont passé la passion est
toujours intacte pour ce supporter de la
première heure instituteur il a été le
témoin privilégié de l'histoire du
football local comme chaque weekend il
était bien sûr de la partie pour la
rencontre opposant Lestac à oser et
notre partenaire de Canal 32 l'a
accompagné au Stade de l'Aube regardez
comme avant chaque match de l'Estac
régie Senri se prépare au mois de
février il fêtera ses 100 ans les années
ont passé les souvenirs se brouille
parfois la passion du football elle est
toujours intacte pour ce supporter de la
première heure je suis né le 10 février
1924 quand j'étais jeune j'ai fait du
football bon j'étais supporteur de la de
la STS et puis tous ceux qui ont suivi
je suis allé au stade de l'auavis qu
j'avais j'avait 12 ans le Stade de
l'Aube rég le connaî bien il est né peu
avant son inauguration les derb face au
Reims de juste fontaine la Coupe
d'Europe à l'OB des années 2000 ce
samedi après-midi c'est un autre derby
qu'il s'apprête à vivre face au voisins
au serroi 14h sonne l'heure de partir
pour le stade Régis n'a plus de voiture
c'est Roland son ami qui assurera le
tragé une amitié insolite née il y a 8
ans la première rencontre que j'ai fait
avec régie c'était au stade de l'au
j'allais prendre mes places et puis j'ai
vu arriver Régis alors ben j'ai dit
qu'est-ce que vous faites ben il me dit
je fais vos match oh là sais bien j'ai d
venez avec moi j'ai une place de livre
attendez qu'il me dit je vais je vais
prendre la place j'ai non je vous la
donne on y va ensemble à 15h le coup
d'envoi est donné et l'ambiance est au
rendez-vous 90 minutes plus tard
malheureusement c'est la douche froide
pour les stacs desfites de bu à je
reviendrai quand même comme n'importe
quel supporter régiss s déçu il reste
malgré tout philosophe avec l'espoir
d'avoir encore quelques beau matchs
devant lui l'année prochaine Régis et
son épouse Lilian auront tous les de 100
ans
il faut courir vite mais surtout ne pas
en perdre une goutte la course des
garçons de café de Grenoble est
l'occasion de mettre en avant les
métiers de la restauration et de
l'hôtellerie dans cette épreuve atypique
le vainqueur n'est pas forcément le plus
rapide vous allez le voir Émilien
d'ailleurs le vainqueur du jour l'a
expliqué à Ambre crossé pour
téléGrenoble ça fait plaisir un peu
essouffler parce que étonnamment on a
quand même 400 m à parcourir donc c'est
c'est assez imposant le plus dur dans
l'épreuve c'est vraiment
tout sur le plateau de pas faire
renverser tout en
prenant les distances avec chacun voilà
c'est bien d'amortir sur les jambes et
puis et puis on regarde tout droit quoi
voilà de futurs serveurs donc qui
deviendront peut-être someliier et
serviront à leur clients l'unique vin
récolté à Paris c'est d'ailleurs notre
partenaire 20 minutes TV qui a assisté
au vendange à Paris au clomontmartre on
regarde le
reportage depuis 8h ce matin les
employés de la Ville de Paris coupent
les grappes de raisins le clot
Montmartre livre la récolte de sa
nouvelle cuvée de vin une véritable
tradition on va faire quelque chose
d'assez exceptionnel dans une ville
aussi dense que Paris et dans un un
arrondissement aussi dense que 18e on va
on va couper du raisin on va faire de
l'agriculture parce que le 18e c'est
Montmartre c'est aussi un arrondissement
agricole et donc tous les ans au mois de
septembre on vendange on coupe le raisin
on offre ce raisin au comité des fêtes
et d'Action Social du 18e qui vont faire
du vin et on prépare ce grand moment de
la vie de l'arrondissement qui est la
fête des Mang et les grappes de raisin
parisiennes ne quittent pas un seul
moment le 18e arrondissement on fait le
vin physiquement dans la mairie je crois
que c'est la seule mairie de France à
l'intérieur de laquelle on fait du vin
et ce qui est atypique aussi c'est cette
continuité depuis 90 ans on fait ce jus
de raisin puiss vin et on le fait au
bénéfice des plus pauvres et des plus en
difficulté au sous-sol de la mairie les
grabes arrivent par caisse première
étape trier les grains destinés au vin
rouge et au
rosé ça c'est pas mur par exemple ça ça
c'est c'est pas mur l'idéal pour un vin
rouge c'est avoir des petites grappes
avec des petits graass pour un rosé
c'est d'avoir des des grappes qui on
vont avoir une taille un peu plus grande
et qui vont avoir surtout beaucoup plus
de jus processus de vinification en
trois étapes la première les raflage les
rafles c'est ça c'est la partie verte de
la grappe ça c'est la rafle donc on va
enlever parce que ça donne des goûts
végétaux amer les raésins passent
ensuite dans le ballon du pressoir puis
la cuve de macération où ils reposeront
une à 3 semaines si le processus est le
même impossible de savoir le goût de
cette nouvelle cuvée c'est ça qui est
intéressant ave le vin c'est qu'il est
différent tous les ans et pour le
découvrir il faudra attendre la fin de
la période d'élevage du vin les 1500
bouteilles seront vendues lors de la 91e
édition de la Fête des vendange en 2024
voilà avant de nous quitter je vous
propose de partir à la découverte d'un
trésor bien gardé la basilique de pibc à
quelques kilomètres de Toulouse cette
basilique Saint-Germain fait forte
impression ce monument de style
romano-byzantin est unique en son genre
et Mathis Gardan et Clément Gassi sont
nos guides pour la Dépêche du
Midi elle est particulière d'abord parce
qu'elle a pas été finie hein et que
j'étais un projet qui était
surdimensionné par rapport à la taille
du village il y a une église et une
basilique juste face à face c'est quand
même énorme on a un hôtel rond aussi ce
qui est quand même pas tout à fait
normal normalement
un hôtel devrait être rectangulaire et
on a pris un petit os du pied de
saintegermain dans le les reliques que
l'on a et on a scellé dans l'hôtel un
méatars tar un méthatarce de l'hôtel de
pied de Saint-Germain il n'y a aucune
dorure il y a rien de cher il y a rien
mais il y a que des choses qui sont
données avec le cœur c'està-dire vous
avez beaucoup de tapisseries qui ont été
données saint gerermain méritait d'avoir
une basilique on s'aperçoit qu'il y
avait eu des miracles en Pag qu'il y
avait des choses et quand on regarde
maintenant ce qui se passe avec les gens
qui viennent mais il se passe toujours
des choses extraordinaires mais il n'est
pas rare moi quand je fais des des
visites comme ça que les gens viennent
de me dire vous savez je suis miraculeux
de
Saint-Germain voilà c'est la fin de
cette édition merci à vous de l'avoir
suivi on se retrouve très vite pour une
nouvelle édition du Grand JIT des
territoires au revoir à
[Musique]
tous